مجرد مشاهد غير عادية هذا الصباح
في قاعة المحكمة هذه هنا في وسط كييف ،
ضع في اعتبارك أنه بينما كنا نتحدث
عن هذه الأيام القليلة الماضية معًا ،
ما هو غير عادي في هذه المحاكمة
هو أنها تجري
حتى مع استمرار الحرب الآن ، فهي تغطي
تلك القليلة الأولى  أيام الحرب ، فاديم
شيشيماروف متهم بقتل
مدني أعزل كان يركب
دراجته على هاتف
في قريته ليست بعيدة عن منزله
اليوم في المحكمة الآن للتو حصلت أرملته على
فرصة للتحدث إلى فاديم شيشيماروف
الذي أقر بالذنب  الآن
لقتله ، استمع ،
هل يمكنك من فضلك أن تخبرني بما شعرت به
عندما قتلت زوجي.
شاب
يبلغ من العمر 21 عامًا وما سمعناه في المحكمة بعد
ذلك التبادل غيره بالفعل تحدث
عن الفوضى التي سادت تلك الأيام القليلة ، دبابته ،
وهي وحدة تنزل
من الحدود الروسية تصطدم
بلغم أرضي  ووجد رجاله يفرون في
سيارة مسروقة
ووجدوا أنفسهم في القرية
قبل مقتل ذلك المدني
بقليل ولم نسمع من شاشيماران اليوم
سمعنا من جندي آخر كان
يسافر أيضًا في تلك السيارة
أسير حرب روسي آخر يتحدث عن
الفوضى.  عند التحدث إلى الضغط الذي تعرضت له
الشيشة مارين لإطلاق النار
، كان مترددًا في البداية في القيام بذلك ،
فقد أُمر بالقيام بذلك وشعرت حقًا
بالفوضى التي واجهها هؤلاء الشباب
لأنهم وجدوا أنفسهم في
موقف لم يفعلوه هم أنفسهم
فهم صحيح